[Musique]
c'est pour moi un grand privilège comme
je les dis d'être en face de vous ce
soir et c'est pour partager avec vous
quelques chose c'est pour plutôt me
confesser parce que bon ça fait
longtemps je me suis pas confessé et
j'ai choisi donc le cas du tennis
aujourd'hui pour me confesser avec vous
mais avant je voulais savoir est-ce que
parmi vous il ya des gens qui ont des
idées aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il ya parmi
vous des gens qui pense à des choses
aujourd'hui qu'il pour laquelle ils sont
conscients que c'est irréalisable ou
pour laquelle ils sont conscients que ça
ne sera pas réalisé avant le terme de
leur show je suppose il ya des gens par
nouveau par exemple qui pensent qu'ils
peuvent faire un voyage sur le soleil
par exemple est ce qu'il ya des gens
parmi vous qui ont des idées aussi folle
et qui sont conscients qu'ils ne
pourront pas le réaliser si oui le vélo
doit s'il vous plaît ceux qui savent
qu'ils ont décidé qu'ils ne pourront pas
réaliser
franchement pas ce que me dire qu'ils
iront sous le soleil on est d'accord il
ya au moins une dizaine de personnes ici
et moi je suis là pour sept personnes
essentiellement pour vous dire que de
moments où vous le pensez vous pouvez le
réaliser on va créer un petit un petit
voyage ensemble si vous permettez je
suis steve wallace et je peux vous dire
donc que vous êtes l'incarnation du
possible sur l'année d'accord je suis
venu à cotonou en 2007
moi j'ai grandi à porte nouveaux
comportements ville natale mon gros
village comme j'aime l'appeler et quand
je venais à cotonou donc c'était
vraiment comme tout le monde pour errer
en tout cas on est en mode exode et
gérait comme tout comme beaucoup de
jeunes n'allait pas où j'allais je
travaillais j'allais à l'école parce que
mon père voulait ça moi j'aime pas
pouvoir mais bon moi j'y allais et
deux ans après j'ai un de mes meilleurs
frère mon frère en tout cas aux états
unis qui m'a appelé savage hier il m'a
appelé et c'est ce que j'appelle le
déclic et j'espère au terme de cette
séance
vous aurez aussi un déclic j'espère que
peut-être deux mais vous aurez aussi un
des clips dans vos vies jir m'a appelé
et m'a dit ce type ça va j'ai dit oui
dit écoute tu ça pendant 2009 là j'ai
dit oui il dit mais sache que ici aux
etats-unis en mai en 2050 et kobe mais
vous êtes encore en 1960 dit qu'est ce
que tu as là tu es parti à peine deux
ans et de quoi tu parles on dit non les
gens ont un mental d'acier ici les gens
ont un mental de conquérant ici les gens
rendent les choses impossibles possible
c'est juste ça qui m'a dit il a
raccroché et depuis lors ma vie a changé
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a
mis en place les mois une organisation
que beaucoup de gens connaissent ici
pour impacter notre communauté
parce qu'aujourd'hui que vous soyez
soudeur maçon menuisier styliste vous
avez une valeur ajoutée apportée à votre
communauté vous avez quelque chose à
donner
vous êtes né pour briller vous êtes né
pour briser et je veux que vous brisez
au terme de cette séance c'est important
que chacun de nous ici présent que nous
puissions prendre conscience de la
valeur ajoutée que nous pouvoir apporter
à nos communautés respectives vous êtes
une boule d'énergie
vous avez des défauts mais vous avez des
qualités aussi mettre en avant ses
qualités
ayez le déclic et donc après ça après ce
déclic donc en a mis en place cette
organisation d'avoir mené beaucoup
d'activité et je le dis le fondement de
notre de notre de notre vie aujourd'hui
va être l'action pour la réussite parce
que les idées c'est bien mais les
actions ci encore mieux et c'est ce que
nous avons fait il ya eu beaucoup de
choses qu'on a mis en place et on s'est
rendu compte que pendant que des gens
étaient investis pour gagner de l'argent
et des entrepreneurs ont été dans le
social on le faisait que du social parce
que le but important pour nous était de
domination se disant waouh
les gens sont contents ou alors j'ai
fait quelque chose devient ma comité
s'était jeté cette façon morale mais qui
n'avait pas de prix et 7 comme ça que ma
vie a changé
et dès lors que j'ai commencé à avoir
plus ou moins un peu d'audience de mes
activités j'ai décidé donc de sortir de
ma zone de confort moi j'ai jamais voulu
voyager parce qu'à la simple idée
d'imaginer que je vais partir
comme l'apple store qui me dit que mon
père était mort ça me rendait fou et
donc je disais je n'avais jamais partie
du bénin le bénin du net je vais mourir
ici les états unis ça peut être sur mars
moi franchement moi je reste blédard
avis et donc après qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en 2012 ma mère m'a dit écoute et
j'en ai marre de toi il faut que tu
viennes et toutes déjà que je la
connaissais pas vraiment et donc j'ai
dit bon ok je viens en europe en
occident et ma porte d'entrée en
occident a été l'italie dans un bon
village de vendée milan on était
peut-être une douzaine de negro et
comment ce voyante sénégalaise
il va rien faire rapidement fait la main
pour être sûr de l'autre là il est
connecté quoi on se dit bon ça c'est un
frère qui en italie et donc j'ai dit à
ma mère que je suis devenu franchement
l'italie samsung c'est comme ça que je
l'exigé dis moi ça m'intéresse pas je
vais aller en france parce que bon pour
le béninois ben voilà défaut d'aller aux
etats-unis moteurs en france demandent
arbres et donc du coup je suis refais
une en france en 2001 en 2012 et j'ai
dis donc vu que je suis sorti de ma zone
de confort qu'est ce que j'allais faire
les liens s'étaient donc d'apprendre et
de compléter mon cursus parce que
j'avais arrêté après la licence en
marketing action commerciale et tout ce
que j'avais fait et donc mes
perfectionner dans tout ce qui était
internet c'est ça qui m'intéressait et
quand vous travaillez pas passion
franchement je n'ai pas l'impression de
travailler
moi j'aimerais travailler sur 12 heures
jeudi a fait 112 à travailler sur des
projets sans m'arrêter et je pense avoir
vu peut-être de l'eau mais il ya eu il
n'y a jamais eu de peine parce que quand
vous travaillez pas pression vous êtes
engagé vous vous portez d'accord et donc
après ça il fallait oser parce que quand
je venais en france il fallait attendre
un temps pour pouvoir avoir mes papiers
officiellement france vous travaillez
pour ceux qui connaissent et donc
c'était il ya devant vous et c'est la
preuve que je dis publiquement j'ai été
sans papiers pendant huit mois en france
ça mon père rival découvrit qu'elle va
voir cette vidéo je sais que vous
m'appelez m'insulter
mais pendant toute cette période je
n'avais pas le choix il fallait soit
être parti en italie pour attendre que
la nouvelle entrée comme on sait que
chez des sous ou que je me débrouille
pour travailler et comme je vous ai dit
rien impossible quand tu as la volonté
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai appelé un
cousin j'ai pris ses papiers et j'ai
travaillé en son nom pendant une année
dans une grande société en france j'ai
des collègues j'ai un collègue qui m'a
écrit lundi passé par hasard parce qu'il
m'a vu sur facebook avec mon identité
que vous connaissez et il m'a appelé par
l'identité qu'il connaît je suis un
témoin aujourd'hui pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis où je suis c'est
pour vous dire que vous devez sortir de
votre zone de confort
des fois on flirte avec des choses mais
je ne vous demande pas de faire des
choses qui ne sont pas orthodoxes mais
j'ai pris des risques pour atteindre des
objectifs qui étaient les miens j'ai
veillé pendant des nuits entières j'ai
pleuré j'ai eu des nouveaux je n'ai pas
pu manger parce que j'avais pas de quoi
manger
mais ça en occident où beaucoup de
personnes c'était le paradis ce n'est
pas le cas il ya un seul chanson qui
était mon hymne au quotidien n'oublie
pas tes racines
lord a germé l'afrique nous est cher et
ça ne l'est jamais et quand je suis
parti j'ai dit que j'allais revenir pour
bâtir ma communauté pour impacter pour
que chaque béninois où qu'il soit n'est
pas besoin d'attendre de penser à
michael jackson avant de réussir parce
que des michael jackson y en a au bénin
il ya des gens que vos enfants vont
connaître quelles vont-être mais qui ne
sont plus en vie parce qu'ils ont fait
des choses bien et c'est à ça qu'on doit
oeuvrer
c'est pour ça qu'on doit exister au delà
d'être d'avoir des like parce que delek
aujourd'hui on en a tous en tout cas moi
j'en ai mais c'est pas le plus important
c'est des pâtes et sa communauté dans
votre domaine et c'est pour ça que je
suis là ce matin pour vous dire que
c'est possible
durante l'impossible que vous pensez
possible dès que vous le pensez ça c'est
des gens qui m'ont motivé quand j'étais
en europe ces gens là je veux que
regarder le nom que vous allez voir les
histoires cdd génie ces gens là c'est
des gens que j'aime bien le quotidien
qui m'ont motivé et sympathie sont loin
parce qu benausse et des documents
motivé vous allez voir ces gens c'est
des gens qui m'ont motivé
cd je ne peut-être pas compris non qui
n'ont pas mon âge mais qui dans leurs
communautés faisait des choses avec le
moyen et c'est à ça que je veux qu'on
ressemble des étoiles que nous puissons
bris
dans ce pays pour notre afrique après
n'oubliez pas derrière chaque réussite
il ya beaucoup d'échecs et ne prenaient
pas les échecs comme des ne prenez pas
les essais com dcom des tomes des choses
qu'on peut pas surmonter non parce que
moi j'ai été aussi commerciale en france
toujours avec ma cause de votre époux
une grande société et un jour j'étais
allé présenter un produit de cette
société et y'a 20 matches de liga je me
rappelle quand c'était hier le monsieur
quand j'ai toqué il a ouvert il m'a vu
il a sorti une arme sur moi je suis
rentré le soir là j'ai dit à ma chérie
avec qui j'étais à l'époque
j'arrête ce boulot pour moi c'était un
échec parce que je l'arrêté
mais quelques mois plus tard j'étais
embauché dans une autre société et je
suis j'ai quitté la france en cdi
après avoit ete stage et dans cette
société c'est vous dire que l'échec
n'était pas derrière est une réussite
aujourd'hui à titre indicatif j'étais
stagiaire en 2008 en 2006 ici à cotonou
une entreprise pour laquelle il y avait
un responsable artistique pour lequel
j'étais un stagiaire j'étais istp à 3000
francs
mais je sais que c'était bien pour moi
aujourd'hui cette personne ait dans mon
équipe je suis 100 responsables c'est un
prêt je suis aujourd'hui l'un des plus
jeunes cac de grandes institutions de la
république ce n'est pas ce qu'il n'est
pas peut-être par hasard c'est vrai vous
avez dès que j'ai pris et que j'assume
je sais que ne fait pas l'unanimité mais
c'est pourquoi je suis là je veux le
faire et ça c'est ma partition et c'est
ça que je voudrais que chacun garde
j'ai voulu partager ces moments intimes
avec vous parce que je n'ai pas souvent
l'occasion de parler de moi et je ne
souhaite pas mais si ça peut aider des
gens avant le déclic c'est un peu plus
percuté des gens à est devenu cio où je
sais qu'il veut franchement c'est le
plus important pour moi je voudrais donc
que vous regardiez ça c'est tout ce que
j'ai à faire comme boulot rapidement
j'étais soudeur pour ceux qui me
connaissent ils voient que ça tout temps
les yeux rouges
je ne suis pas votre peau drogué
je ne suis pas contre un gain mais
j'étais soudeur ici je sais aujourd'hui
que je me fais des fourneaux en tout cas
quand je serai peut-être en galère je
vais peut-être faire des photos mais
j'ai des collègues avec qui j'étais à
l'école et qui sauf que j'étais sous des
représentants ça c'est tout ce que j'ai
pu faire comme boulot en tout cas
aujourd'hui de manière sommaire d'accord
aujourd'hui je suis la démarche n'est
pas ce que je vais faire
d'accord c'est pour vous dire que quel
que soit ce que vous faites n'est pas
peur de semer pour récolter ça prend du
temps mais n'oubliez pas qu'il faut
semer pour récolter
faute de donner pour recevoir ceux qui
ne sont pas prêts à donner ne recevons
pas céder loi naturelle
gardez à l'esprit que votre mental est
votre meilleur laboratoire et que vous
êtes des génies que vous pouvez briller
partout vous serez peut-être ça la
condition est donc ça peut vous dire
après que ces personnes ont eu des
échecs et que moi si tu es stv il ya
quelques années personne ne voulait de
moi d'un galet et aujourd'hui je suis
fier d'être là je suis parce que deux
matches secs et gigean qu'au loin
aujourd'hui c'est stévy je fais le tour
du monde
aujourd'hui j'ai réalisé beaucoup de mes
rêves déjà je n'ai plus voulu voir obama
moi c'était un rêve je ne buvais j'ai
voulu voir des révérends j'ai voulu
faire un tour de las vegas bref c'est
pas pour honorer ma vie c'est pour vous
dire que les rêves qui sont les miens
sont les miens on n'a pas fédéré bon
semble donc je ne peux pas voir mes
rêves à moi taillez vos rêves
assumez les et continue de briller
c'était mon étage